les forêts du congo perd chaque année
environ 400 milles hectares de sa
superficie alors que le bois énergie
constitue l'élément principal qui
occasionne la la déforestation du congo
[Musique]
c'est une entreprise industrielle
environnementale nous sommes dans la
production de solutions d'énergie propre
beaucoup plus respectueuse de forêt
ouais c'est qu'il faut savoir c'est que
plus de 85% de la population utilisent
de l'énergie ligneuse particulièrement
le bois et le charbon la société
nationale d'électricité découvre qu
environ 15 % seulement donc on suppose
que le nerf principal en rdc c'est le
charbon de bois et le bois de chauffage
[Musique]
non
c'est une solution qui qui est beaucoup
plus respectueuse de forêt d'autant plus
que pour en produire on n'a pas besoin
de couper là pour en produire on a
besoin de récupérer les déchets la
rupture démocratique du congo produit 2
millions de tonnes de déchets
biodégradables par an aux côtés de ces
déchets il y avait aussi le
développement de maladies endémiques
paludisme actifs aux ide ainsi de suite
qui classe d'ailleurs la répu
démocratique du congo comme étant le
pays où il ya un taux de mortalité
beaucoup plus élevés liés aux maladies
endémiques donc le maladies liées à la
saleté voilà la raison pour laquelle non
nous récupérons ses déchets et on le
transforme en énergie et on les
transforme également un amendement du
sol
[Musique]
d'abord au départ on utiliser des lions
qui n'était pas vraiment à prendre
d'autant plus que ça a démarré
difficilement donc ça s'allume est
difficilement mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 10 tonnes de production la
journée donc nous sommes en train de
séduire la population a abandonné
l'utilisation de bois pour s'élancer a
de solution beaucoup plus
environnementale qui respectent
l'environnement